president trump is not conceding nor
should he
however yesterday on twitter
hashtag trump conceded was trending
that's very strange why would trump
conceded trend if trump did not concede
president trump has tweeted that just
just this morning he tweeted out
something to the effect of i will win we
won the election
a couple days ago he tweets out rigged
election we will win all caps
another tweet i concede nothing but then
there was a third tweet
and people are misunderstanding this
because they don't know how to speak
trump broadly they don't know how to
speak new yorker but they they
specifically don't have to speak trump
he tweeted out quote he won because the
election was rigged no vote watchers or
observers allowed vote tabulated by
radical left privately owned company
dominion
with a bad reputation and bum equipment
they couldn't even qualify for texas
which i won by a lot
the fake and silent media and more
so they're saying because he said
because trump said he won
referring to biden then he is conceding
the election
now you can say trump doesn't use
proper diction he his grammar is
eccentric you can say all those things
but no one can honestly read
what trump said as him conceding
and my evidence for this is he used the
same
sort of linguistic structure when he was
talking about john mccain you remember
trump got in a lot of trouble because he
said john mccain's not a war hero
are we famous they said johnny is not a
war hero biden continues to attack him
for saying john mccain's not a war hero
the way he said it though was exactly
the way that he said joe biden
didn't win the election joe biden did
win the election take a listen to the
infamous mccain comment
he hit me he's not a war hero he's a
warrior five and a half years he's a war
hero because he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you do you
hear that notorious comment how dare
trump say that okay you can
you can dislike the comment all you like
and you can dislike what he's saying
about joe biden right now
but you have to admit when joe when when
trump says
he won because the election was rigged
what he is saying is
people believe that joe biden won
because the election is rigged
even though he didn't really win just as
he said
john mccain's not a war hero he's a war
hero because he was shot down
he's not he's not contradicting himself
he's not saying john mccain's not a war
hero oh actually he is a war hero he's
saying john mccain's not a war hero
people believe he is a war hero because
he's shot down but nevertheless my
assertion is true he's not a he is not a
war hero
same thing here joe biden did not win
the election
people think he won because you know all
this voter fraud or whatever uh but he
did he didn't really win that's what
he's saying you can disagree with that
all you want
and we'll find out there's gonna be a
legal process that plays out to see who
ends up being
ultimately named president we may never
know who got the most votes
people might have a hunch who got the
most votes but we may never know for
sure
stuffing the ballot box is notoriously
difficult to figure out
it took the the lbj investigators
decades after he
left office to figure that out and it
does happen all the time as we saw with
lbj
and fdr i spoke about that on the show a
little bit last week
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you